hello guys we are back at youtuber we're
going to have a little bit of a special
discussion on a topic that raises a lot
of questions for many aikidoka which is
which ship embody his weapons a lot of
people legitimately wonder where they
come from and what did he do
for what reason where does this fit in
Aikido do you need weapons Aikido some
we say yes some we say no and the
question is your answer yes it's gonna
be which weapons well done is going to
be dependent of what's available around
you so what we proposed today is to talk
to some actual specialists of weapons in
Japan we'll discuss a little bit about
the history of those weapons and we're
going to show them a little bit of
footage from which ba ba ba to get their
impressions on the type of weapon that
he was doing early in his life a bit
later to try to get a better idea from
the more knowledgeable things fancy
self-perception and has a little bit
less biased so I would like to introduce
you to mr. Alex Bennett's dr. Alex
Bennett specialist in in a kingdom
professor at Kansai University and
Batista only who spent a long time at
Buda Buda daikaku and with amongst other
things a specialist in jus kendo bionet
welcome guys oh thank you thank you -
yeah and the third person here with me
today is one person you know well we've
been collaborating from a long time it's
Jody - from the founder of Sato now Jody
comes here because he's got of course
deep knowledge about weapons in terms of
the historic manufacturing and on top of
this he's rather knowledgeable in the
more religious aspects of which robbery
his practice so we're hoping that
through the expect ease of these three
people we can actually draw a more
accurate picture of which Bellinis
practice
[Music]
okay so the first video that I'm going
to show you is the video that dates back
from 1935 which is one of the earliest
videos I know of displaying permanently
which the bobblehead was shot in Osaka
during a period where he was teaching
the I told you it's not the city called
I tell you but it was very much diet or
directed jiu-jitsu at the Asahi
newspaper yeah okay will be very
familiar with that period and they
organized the demonstration and within
the demonstration there are some parts
displaying weapons but it is quite
interesting because this is a very early
phase in English first part is relative
to later videos that we have that are
usually dating from 1952 we've got that
much in between and then because of your
opinion so I'm going to show you a short
clip where he does some salt exercise
using a bookend on his arm and then with
the partner and I'd like to a young
person on that
so those are two clips from 1935 Palace
Hotel result is the one where he's doing
some sort of salt work what were your
impressions well it's really hard to
comment without knowing the exact
context of it but in terms of the
technique looks very awkward
it looks quite rigid as posture this
balance doesn't always look particularly
stable and a lot of power that's going
in to the strikes so in terms of a pure
sort of like swordsmanship perspective
it's like well you know it's like
somebody waving a stick around but
having said that like I said without
knowing the context maybe the objective
is not actually the source and ship as
such it's trying to evoke something else
some kind of physical and mental sort of
coalescence or something like that you
know so me in terms of whether you know
if somebody does a idol or you know saw
that was to see that and saw somebody
doing that that said what the hell
what's going on there
this is like this is just somebody
making stuff up as they go along but if
you look at it from that perspective a
lot again obviously it seems very odd
but I don't believe that that was as
attention it's not actually schwartzman
should such city that is is trying to
demonstrate I mean they would have been
very likely some very competent
swordsmen in the audience forcibly if it
was going to go on the video now that's
regardless of the objective is it fair
to say that the Tecna city the level is
not what you would call as very high
with without any like I said contextual
knowledge just looking at it as it is
and of course the other side of that is
if it is video and it's very old video
and there's a lot about and when you
actually watch somebody do something
live is a different kind of aura that
hits you right and that's obviously
completely we don't even have the sound
right so but just based on that and it's
saying we didn't know who it was just
some old geezer with it with a stick and
it's like really possibly not
you know particularly impressive it you
know a lot about footwork in Aikido or
hope you don't do a Kido just a bit but
not so much but like the food web is
really weird - right yeah photography
that way all the way we moves skipping
and hoping when somebody was always the
feet are not really coordinated but
maybe what makes sense in Aikido yeah is
there any for you but you know that that
will have the same basic posture Aikido
with the triangle which means mr. so
let's open like this
yeah what we call it well of course
entirely depends on the on the new heart
and also the era and whether the
swordsmanship and that you has premise
on whether you're wearing your you are
more exciting like that back or you're
just wearing you know come up and just
normal normal clothes you look at
kenjutsu from schools such as young you
find it's very much front on but you go
back a little bit further and
sidon stuff as well so yeah who
certainly premise with it there's
certainly examples or kind of stats that
points about the honey is something that
historically is not that present in that
value so that would not come from East
Asia to that you would have maintained
while doing weapons in fact it's one of
the normal elements of Aikido compared
to die to you is that honey and of
course it did image question that you
might have is where that honey might
come from
so no I'm just sayin so following on
that looking in history we also know
that which body hey did jookin jutsu in
the army I haven't seen evidence but it
said that you reached a level where he
actually told people and his technique
was rather well regarded within the army
I don't have videos to show you but I
have some pictures that were published
in chin Buddha in 1942 so that's the
next set of documents that I would like
to show you because my assumption was if
the honey does not come from salt is not
present from the dietary techniques then
could it be possibly coming from his
experience in Japan jutsu which was
actually probably one of the first
actually martial art that he formally
trained in so we need to comment on that
right okay
so again as Alex said just before
judging from video as very difficult
especially if it's all video judging
from picture means even more difficult
because it's just you know a fraction of
the time maybe before I was good and
after it was good and then pictures but
at all conversely the picture looks very
good
then before after was really bad can I
can I just have to say that it's likely
that they would have posed for it while
that's fine well - but you know we don't
know the context we don't know nothing
but if you look at that picture only and
you need to make a judgement from that
picture it looks pretty bad
it's something - very difficult to
explain to people with all things you
can do but the position of the left hand
is extremely important you want to
capture and if you come up with you to
some beginner it probably gonna have or
did like this with the hand you know
because it's kind of heavy but or people
might hold it like this like a naginata
all that cocaine unfortunately this is
not very good and the way to or did you
can is like you need to be able to see
the inside of the porn this is correct
posture and it's really weird and people
if you don't do it you can do you will
say what difference it makes if you're
like this one like this it doesn't
change but it change a lot this is very
important so in that picture he holds it
like very from below this looks a bit
strange to be understand but it's come
he's very high he has his finger here
like this it's like it looks like a
beginner two idiots now a few things you
might say okay but the way we teach you
can do nowadays it might be different
from but in the day is right because
weapons are different blah blah blah but
you said the pictures come from
Buddha 1942 in 1942 I don't remember
which issue but maybe November some
things are the same year anyway there's
an article from a Gucci
sense remember his first name anyway is
in which sensor is the the guy who kind
of formalized you can do during the war
and is the world many books attic
and everything and there's an article in
Qin Buddha by ujiie-sensei the same year
where he explains the importance of this
much kata and the position of the feet
and everything and what he is written
there is almost what we have noticed in
the textbook of it you can do it doesn't
change much so again so what which about
does on that picture looks very
different is it a good thing or is it a
bad thing if you made up a song you can
boast fortune kenjutsu stuff for Aikido
what they told you or even that maybe
it's good but if you ask the question is
it good you can do what you can do to us
it was taught back in the days and it's
no under no size now we say possible
back back in the day they were still
using what they were using we - infinity
does she not ready to say money in your
hands and gonna stay where it is but and
that's what I have to type here because
actually in the modern sport if you're
if you're holding it in the wrong place
which is what you use it to get extra
distance right there then it becomes a
home so-called penalty so I mean if he
was techniques they used to be used like
reputation being included - Kim G -
dates back from World War one one one
room in Russia Russia and Russia so it
predates the families of origin by 30
years well in that case it might be
possible because
run war one I mean women like a root
soldier right
19:06 yes 19:06 you can do is probably
because of phosphates no footage nothing
or if there is footage it's like very
bad quality it is probably a bit
different from wall water that's for
sure
how much different it's hard to tell if
you watch and if you read the textbooks
from both days it is already very close
to what we do know there but you will
have some techniques that don't exist
anymore like with very high techniques
up like that but again this watch kata I
don't know and I can't I can tell to be
honest it was a question from another
perspective and as researchers you might
have and beginning of an answer to that
is that if his repetition came from the
fact that he was good on the battlefield
and that some of the people he was
fighting we say that he did some amazing
things on the battlefield from a Buddha
perspective we focus on techniques and
the accuracy of techniques but it
possible that the actual qualities
require you to be a good fighter on the
battlefield and that connected with the
technical material video that would
explain why some people say that we
should I was amazing on the battlefield
but was actually not that much technical
capacities but more maybe courage or
some values that we came back to the
wiki right away
now judge nobody is what people say 50
years ago but some one we did something
for years even before that so somewhat
sorry I mean I mean if if the the
question is I mean from that picture is
it good you can do or do kenjutsu from
you know back in the days of 1942 then
no does does it make it like bad I don't
know maybe created is on system and but
like if you want to compare it to what
is you can do what you can do sue then
it is different and maybe not good but
that's fair to say also that obviously
Duke and it wasn't this may exactly go
right and so I mean we're in assignment
away and do a number of different but
all disciplines at the same time I agree
matter and you Kendall Kendall yo-yo and
so on and so forth and what's the one of
them is always going to take precedence
so for me personally I do these other
martial arts but my base is Kendall even
when I do
Coco you know like touching machine did
you cheat on you or something like that
which is very very different kind of
Kauai and movement breathing and so
forth to modern Kendall but the way that
I do my dick she video is pretty much
based on the way that I did kinder so
some people will criticize there as
being too Kendall ish saying I did make
another making that error is very much
side on because it's a long weapon
Kinder's front on and somewhere I need
up in the middle
so the thing which is often criticized
it's not being pure and Aegina and
that's because it's not my main thing
it's not where I came from and so I mean
look at those photos Richie but when he
is hoping a mortgage or something like
that it's some it's to make it stands to
reason that if there was not his primary
focus to start with there obviously
there's going to be some idiosyncrasies
well you were also talking about the
harmony and again a bad picture is fit
position is a bit awkward but so the
question is back is detect the harmony
from you can do all you can Jitsu
important t.t to title you or Aikido I
don't know it might be a field apartment
the opposite may be had with Aikido ha
me already and is using it when he does
you can Jitsu because it looks a bit
like that on the picture yeah two things
about that position looking at it it
looks very similar to his feet position
so more Aikido feet position all the way
down to lay down his life this is what
you would call as I did on me now but
it's not that you can do and I don't
think it's I mean the name the Aikido
was actually registered at the die
little guy in 1942 so I did or might
have been sort of kind of starting to be
formulated then but the thing is this is
not fit position introduced you would
see in title you so basically the
question remains
doesn't come from title you it does not
come from salt seems from what you said
and this is not typical you can do even
like Alex just said I mean if he did
almost difference
then maybe ended up somewhere in your
locker like between you can Doha me
which is like diabetes naginata hunger
which is very more more on me and then
kendo what can you still be like if you
do all this stuff and you kind of do and
have your age and then you end up like I
don't know it's just to position but you
know I wouldn't read too much into
pictures anywhere on pictures not only
pictures but the fact that Aikido is the
name it's discipline was registered in
1942 that was because it came under that
the umbrella of a daily pompadour like
coddle candid as well and many other
martial arts were brought into it even
though they were private societies or
organizations in their own right and
putting the door was really just to be
recognized or as part of the club as it
were right and so I don't really know a
bit of base indicative of the fact that
you suddenly really branched out into
this amazing new system and you've sort
of been enlightened to a lot of new
things right so John oh yeah he doesn't
even come from me Yeah right but on that
topic obviously kind of jiggle he didn't
have to do a lot of technical changes to
get registration the dining pond to be
had his arts taught in schools and
competitions to happen do you reckon
that there might have been some requests
placed on whichever morihei to do the
same to change somehow the techniques to
fit them no this is just conjecture
really but in terms of common duel and
his relationship the tiny bubble talk is
a little bit complicated actually
because the tiny puppet okay judo was
not really cool come actually so when
you talk about judo this is sort of like
two kinds
is the dock a judo and it's the chordal
Han judo and even though come optical I
was very much involved in the
establishment of jiu-jitsu in the great
which later became called judo they're
really you've got to think of them as
sort of like separate things and come on
do you I was in he was in fact involved
right from the very outset and creating
yukata from the birddog I for both
Kendall and for what became the dog play
judo as well to be taught in schools and
education system but caller can't always
maintain its own independence as well it
was just that in the war years these
organizations were officially brought
into what under government control that
seems to it so come on do you know never
made any sort of well what do you say
compromises or something like that to
suitum a militaristic agenda as such to
be recognized and I wouldn't have
thought that Hui about what he here
would have done the same
so well but having said that it was an
interesting time of course Japan was at
war and all of the martial arts to a
certain extent where the focus really
was was changed something from something
spiritual something what physical
education personal development and so
forth that something that could be
utilized in some capacity at the front
in war so kendo itself changed and what
at their time as well the rules changed
the length of the shinai change to make
it more realistic closer to a katana
usually kendo matches what they call
someone shoulders fun the first
score two points wins but became one
solver because you get hit by a sword
that said there's no second chance and
it was grappling was brought in to
Kindle as well so you see that just as a
natural sort of I guess you could say
evolution or devolution insulin or you
look at it given the times they're
certain things that change I was in the
various boudoir but there's a conscious
the kind of decision to make it fit in
with various criteria perhaps at the
government-issued I doubt very much at
all right because I would have thought
that if it were to be taught in schools
might have been changed rather just
softly to bother them but I think Aikido
really was taught in schools as an
official subject maybe there was school
clubs extracurricular clubs might seem
to be corrected but the Ministry of
Education guidelines stipulated that
boys would either do judo or kendo and
girls make another doll as they called
it then and and coudl also Sumon was a
part of it as well towards the war years
other drills in Jiu canyons example what
you guys are lucky any yeah we're
incorporating but Aikido self I mean it
was very good very exclusive yes this
fight was registering 42 okay it was
introducing yes yeah but I have
photographic evidence which interesting
I don't have you able to learn sent to
you from a book by Atacama where the
Solon where the last chapter actually
has some pictures of girls which are in
the legend of the picture is written
that they're practicing I see Buddha and
that's in the middle two waits for a
light forces in school sugar Cole I was
also with
article in chibuto see like that all new
self-defense for women yes there is that
so there are three things for policemen
for women and days those first pictures
looks like bamboo and it's in a school
and it's called IP puto so I was
bothering you
hang on but they have been possibly Ikey
whatever that is to fix you behind us in
schools at the time and in this case
that would have made sense that
registration is died upon to go by if
that was the case even if it was in the
smaller scale so it was extremely rare
probably very valuable photograph
actually because we see by money here
was pretty much most of his life against
really making his food or a major thing
right but he did have a number of quite
influential students I think that was by
design on his behalf and perhaps it was
their political influence well in this
case that might have been he says doing
and and that brings up another point
when she I the hill I mean who who seems
to be the one who's been linking with
the IT guy in the body politic I said
that behind that term Aikido was not
supposed to be only wish was Aikido but
a whole bunch of different digits more
or less styling with Ikey and to me if
any is us is at Akuma's teaching will
have been rather good fit for that same
googling what he died said
you know what is really stitching what
it was teaching at the bank but actually
wasn't teaching that much of a hero was
doing like two swore strange stuff that
we've never seen that we should be doing
so you just have tried to pack up is all
yes I mean it certainly is the statement
that he made that the ejido time was
supposed to encompass all the
disciplines has been debated and it is
Sam Jones one of the people who actually
expressed some criticism not reasonable
some doubt but that's an open question
that pictures just reminded me that like
really used conferences and when he says
the Aikido is a believer so it's
everything what you can pretty much take
whatever you want from that statement
but it doesn't really help the case
though one thing is that you kept
contact with Lisa I thought she sat
akuma during the association Boone years
and then taking a sabbatical to cover
the teaching so then that was
takenaga-kun told it has group they all
got church daily which is the same level
as what we should from together but she
said that the major problem is the only
one who called manger biden from from
Takeda from technical reasons it was
another one because more likely under a
big title so there is that that mix in
Jesus teach engines subsequent to my
students but the thing is he never lost
contact with vegetable and in 54 six
ever remember when he received an AIDS
done I to do from Vichy bar and there is
evidence that there are pictures of the
diploma in depictions of the ceremony
whiskey shaman was here and so he sat
akama
kept links with wish I'm told that might
even have taught at home I don't have
evidence of this but but some people
didn't have said so they could have been
more together than we than we think so
that's just out there
perhaps we can now we've looked at the
jugen we've got the sword already on
perhaps we can now switch to later in
the whispers life and which basically
the videos we have started about 52
unfortunately we don't have much in
between we've got quite a lot after that
so just an interest for the post videos
having been a part of the tiny bump
little guy during the war years
forcibly I believe was I kid also
subject to the blanket ban on the doll
that was imposed yeah by GHQ and the
Ministry of Education movie theater the
Robert I think the apk never closed
right the KU bukan was never officially
disbanded we defend
in fact it's endured the wish my family
was advised by whoever at the local guy
or in the government to move the
headquarters to Yama much further from
the occupation
[Music]
I think you you read the wall gsq notice
is a document right yeah but I think
there was a lot of like exceptions or
special status for that people will step
like that it wasn't the same exact same
status for all good all right yeah
interestingly and again I stand to be
corrected here but my understanding is
that karate
didn't actually come under the bed it'll
still sort of people were practicing
that and obviously
applications as well which American GIs
a particularly very attracted to goes
well yeah but well Kim though it's slow
like it's a little bit disjointed
because the case Joe the police force
were still practicing king of even
though it had been banned everywhere
else and then suddenly I think was
nineteen forty nine swords about three
years after the ban was imposed suddenly
it was it was banned and the police as
well so they came up with a brand new
martial art called um no no no no no I
told you was a students present danger
too it was kind of a tight ones it's a
night battle techniques which just
happen to use a bamboo stick about the
same sizes as you know and just happen
to have the same equipment that the
police needed to be trained at these
kind of things to maintain public water
coordinates to using a defender I don't
know I think it was a fine line between
a GPS you know I've ever seen but I sort
of wonder with regard to Aikido I know
that you know people even though it was
especially bad people but I kind of
remember seeing one day on YouTube maybe
or somewhere a weird video of police
people are doing some weird stick stuff
there be it might be it I look for it
maybe it's but I mean did a bit of
Kendall to buy it was like they
basically body before killed my steps
and I think there's no video someone
YouTube I'm pretty sure that they would
have continued to practice martial arts
in the countryside all
even you can do which was like the most
bad fear you are teaching they were
still running after the ban discussed
within the American forces like this
martial artists as traumatized who is
with nationalism like Aikido had pretty
dirty history before during the war
because of the Sakura Chi and all this
histories of meetings were held at the
kabukiman and Rafi but did teach at the
mystery minis well many of us all his
students would rely upon the military
winter but I mean maybe that's what I
was trying to try and get it my guess is
like um well Aikido it was such a small
but really comparatively speaking it was
a very small group I mean in comparison
was just so much bigger judo was just so
much bigger when we're talking about you
know hundreds of thousands of people and
don't even drink and I guess with a few
thousands people and most maximum yeah
like basically everybody India he was
doing to Kendall at one point and Duncan
doors along yes oh okay no no itself
that sort of became official again with
the creation of the which painting the
figuration I think was about nineteen
fifty two which is the date of the video
that you've gonna show us right and I'm
sort of wondering um who if what is
significant about that particular year
for Aikido was it a kind of I know judo
was was allowed to be practiced a little
bit earlier I think was about nineteen
fifty so depending on the boodle the
tree was different king of them
particularly strict
against because of the obviously
connection with the katana and the
various trust
is that are connected with the katana
from the war years but Aikido I really
am curious to know that the kind of
treatment that ever received how it was
viewed and in this video 1952 or in a
bazillion films but I feel like I
remember some writings about a student's
wish why we say that the door was closed
they wasted training inside but they
could just couldn't open the door they
had to open that they took a look like
yeah dad open the door for Refugees you
know that's you yeah rule that while I
was standing committed but very quickly
they separated they made a little bit of
room for training in the refugee state
in one part I do not remember the actual
year of creation of the aikikai
foundation but there in 1952 let me
judge
he returned 48 to Tokyo hmm
48 was realizing I was and that's for
those times anyway
[Music]